increases transability to humans you're
saying that's not gain of function that
is correct and and senator Paul you do
not know what you are talking about his
response is that his experts at the NIH
have judged this up and down the chain
have judged this not to be gain of
function research well this is very
intriguing so what we have been
requesting for two years is the
discussion if his scientists discussed
and debated and concluded that this was
not gain of function research let us see
the deliberation so these are not
classified documents but still the NIH
is more secretive at this point than the
CIA it's a crime it's a felony to lie to
Congress it's punishable to up to five
years in prison after we determined that
fouchy did lie to Congress that indeed
he had funded gain of function research
we submitted the evidence to uh the
Attorney General to meric Garland but
unfortunately he's not done anything
with it